scp-999 also known as the tickle monster
it's one of the most adorable beloved
and undeniably wholesome anomalies ever
to exist in the scp foundation's
containment facilities its mere presence
can cause joy and comfort cure
depression and other mental illnesses
and even sometimes cause violent and
unpredictable creatures to really mellow
out if you're a fan of this channel
chances are that you're a big fan of
scp-9992
but that doesn't mean everyone is on
board
as we all know there are plenty of
entities and groups in the scp universe
that are downright evil and as a result
would love to see this little blob of
pure joy crush to a pulp or sacrifice to
a cosmic horror but you can't ever
underestimate wait a second is that a
containment breech alarm all foundation
staff members report to the affected
cell immediately it looks like an scps
escape containment and is now
in our world that's right
scp-999 has broken out of scp foundation
control and now you can finally have a
tickle monster of your very own in plush
form this super adorable plush from scp
swag is 11 inches of huggable squeezable
joy and now that the tickle monster is
out of containment you can bring it into
your own home tickle monster plushies
are available for pre-order now and all
orders made in the next 10 days also get
a special limited first edition card
worldwide shipping is also available so
go to scp-swag.com right now and
pre-order your own tickle monster and
let us know in the comments what scp
anomalies you want to see in plush form
next
but as we were saying you can't ever
underestimate scp-999
not only is it tickled scp-682 into
submission there are also certain
theories floating around the foundation
that it will one day grow so powerful
its forces of pure goodness and joy can
overthrow the scarlet king himself
that's why today we're throwing the
tickle monster into a kind of royal
rumble with all the baddest dudes the
foundation has ever encountered and
we're going to give our theories on how
scp-999 might somehow find the good and
even the blackest of hearts first
scp-096 the shy guy a killing machine so
brutal direct and opaque in its motives
that some have even questioned whether
it actually has sentience however we'd
personally stake our claim that it does
when a photo of this savage beast was
taken with scp-978
the desire camera a camera that shows
the deepest desire of its subjects it
revealed that the shy guy secretly just
had the desire to disappear not only
does this suggest that the monster may
not actually like killing people but the
very idea that it can have a desire also
implies some level of intelligence but
how would
scp-999 enter the mix well we know that
096 is an anxious creature it spends the
majority of its time just pacing itself
and when someone sees its face it begins
sobbing uncontrollably before entering
its rage state does this sound like a
happy entity to you if the shy guy
encountered 999 at its full joy-giving
power we'd personally think that it
might finally chill out a little perhaps
it'd take a moment to breathe and
contemplate life a little more maybe it
would wonder why it's so ashamed of its
face and feels the need to hunt down and
kill anyone who sees it after all there
are much uglier anomalies like scp-106
he's the next monster to join this weird
wild cage match against scp-999
while 096 is violent 106 is downright
malevolent he's not just sentient but
extremely intelligent the old man loves
causing pain and suffering for his own
perverse pleasure just as much as heavy
hitters like scp-682
so surely 999 would have its work cut
out for it here well not necessarily
there are two leading theories about who
106 actually is one being the scranton
theory and the other the corporal
lawrence theory the first dictates that
106 is the result of dr robert scranton
physically and mentally transformed by
his time in scp-3001
the terrifying red reality the second
theory was that he was a world war one
soldier known as corporal lawrence whose
anomalous encounter in the trenches
turned him into the beast he is today in
either case he's a man shaped by pain
and anomalous trauma much like 096 the
desire camera revealed an insight into
106's mind his greatest desire consists
of him walking across a field towards an
old house where an old woman smiles and
waits for him many believe this old
woman to be his estranged wife perhaps
an encounter with scp-999 would cause
106's sadism to abate reminding him of
the humanity he once had maybe he'd
become a kindly old man in the aftermath
who prefers werther's originals to
violence and spinning long rambling
yarns about the war rather than chasing
people around his terrifying pocket
dimension it's a thought so sweet it
could almost make you sick thankfully
one of our favorite doctors is next on
the list specifically the plague doctor
scp-049
while he definitely isn't as dangerous
or malicious as either of his
predecessors 049 has racked up quite a
body count in his hundreds of years of
operations he sees pestilence everywhere
he goes except within and can kill with
a mere touch however his deadly touch
only seems to apply to non-anomalous
animals and humans not other anomalies
so he definitely couldn't harm 999 and
the tickle monster conversely could
definitely touch him back while the
plague doctor is the serious type he
might not be able to keep his bedside
manner after a serious tickling and we'd
be more than willing to hedge our bets
on him having the laugh of an angel
while zero four nine may have folded in
the face of 999's tickling wrath our
next contestant is as solid as a rock
well technically as solid as concrete
that's because it's scp-173
also known as the sculpture or the
peanut it shows no emotions and murders
anything that blinks in its presence by
snapping its neck but 999 doesn't even
have bones let alone a neck so scp-173
has nothing with which to threaten this
happy little blob and what about
scp-999's counter-offensive if the
tickle monster got its slime all over
scp-173
it might finally reform this statuesque
serial killer through prolonged exposure
maybe after that 173 will finally give
relaxing neck massages rather than
snapping them but while the sculpture
may be intimidating it's nothing
compared to an unkillable mass murdering
blade master right of course we're
talking about scp-076
also known as able no matter how many
times he gets put down he keeps coming
back with unparalleled skills in
physical combat and the ability to pull
huge blades out of thin air he also
appears to be fueled by pure unstoppable
rage so how on earth could our adorable
little tickle monster possibly go
toe-to-toe with a swordsman who cuts
through elite mobile task force soldiers
like a hot knife through a d-class much
like
scp-106 it seems like a lot of abel's
rage is rooted in a deep pain caused by
his past if he truly is the biblical
abel it's likely that his rage stems
from being the very first murder victim
betrayed and killed by his brother kane
now known as
scp-073 spending time with scp-999 might
finally calm him down enough to actually
work through some of these issues and
come to a sense of closure maybe with
scp-999 at his side able could attend
some therapy sessions with foundation
psychologists until he finally felt as
though he'd move past his murderous
urges perhaps even working up to family
counseling with kane he could then
re-enter society and reapply his expert
knife skills and become a bobby flay
style celebrity chef except one who
could actually flay you if you got on
his bad side but let's talk about an scp
that's frankly dangerous to even discuss
i am of course referring to
scp-2521 okay great i'm not dead
wonderful let's carry on
2521 is attracted to any information
about it written or spoken it will
immediately appear upon the creation of
this information and steal either the
information itself or the person
disseminating it in the case of verbal
words if someone were to pass scp-999 a
fact sheet about scp-2521
it would inevitably manifest and prepare
to throw down but perhaps the positive
influence of scp-999 would change
scp-2521's tune rather than obsessively
stealing information about itself the
being may instead finally open up and
speak about itself we might even learn
some interesting things like the fact it
used to have a bowling team with scp-106
and
scp-049 he also loves knitting oh come
on not again
[Music]
now how about we go for something a
little closer to human please
scp-082 ferdinand the cannibal a huge
ogre-like humanoid that has a penchant
for pathological lies and also devouring
human heads and well the rest of the
body on and well the rest of the body
too if he's worked up enough of an
appetite he's super strong and has a
hide so thick that seemingly no weapon
can penetrate it how could scp-999
possibly go around with a behemoth like
this lucky for 999 fernan has an
extremely cheerful temperament if a
potential victim can keep him amused
often listening and playing along with
his elaborate fantasies it massively
increases their chance of survival and
considering scp-999 is literally a good
vibes machine there's a good chance that
it'd keep ferdinand so amused that the
thought of getting hangry wouldn't even
cross his mind once again little scp-999
takes home the w but what about a real
sadist a truly heartless monster whose
commitment to focused endless cruelty is
genuinely unparalleled we're talking
about the being from scp-3999
this terrifyingly powerful reality
warper hasn't racked up scores of
victims because it prefers the quality
of suffering over quantity it'll select
a single victim trap them in their own
personal hell and spend a literal
eternity conceiving every possible
torture and torment to break the spirit
and body of the victim never giving them
the luxury of death however if an entity
could turn the tables and break the
spirit of scp-3999
it would be
scp-999 picture it thousands of years
where the monster tries everything it
can to break the tickle monster's spirit
only to find its own spirit being broken
as scp-999 doesn't succumb to any of it
and continues to project love and
kindness throughout could you imagine
anything more frustrating for a creature
like 39.99 eventually would probably get
so frustrated that it would let 999 go
and find some hapless foundation
researcher to torture instead going up
against a single anomalous being
regardless of its power is one thing but
taking on an entire group is another
challenge for scp-999
what if 999 became trapped in scp-3008
the endless ikea surrounded by the
deadly staff in the middle of the night
our theory is that the positive presence
of scp-999 would really help the
nightmarish malformed staff of this
accursed ikea turn their lives around
and start creating a more positive work
environment around the store rather than
trying to chase survivors trapped inside
the store and beat them to death they
would instead help them find the ideal
furniture for enhancing their lifestyle
if they ever managed to escape the
building 999 would help them go from
horrifying to helpful in no time it'd be
so nice in there that the survivors
wouldn't even want to leave but what
about groups of interest let's say the
chaos insurgency has broken into a
containment site in another one of its
classic raids against the foundation
would a group of elite chaos insurgency
operatives be able to take down the
tickle monster we think not while these
anomaly stealing militants may be
hardcore compared to your average joe
they're nowhere near as hateful or
irredeemable as the likes of 682 or 106.
chances are if they've spent any amount
of time around 999 they'd experience a
sudden sense of mellowness and begin to
rethink all of their poor life choices
but what about the goc those government
stooges obsessed with killing any
anomaly they can get their hands on
personally we theorize that a run-in
with scp-999 and the immensely positive
feelings it causes would cause them to
re-evaluate their entire philosophy on
the anomalies they encounter and lead
them to restructure their entire
organization from the ground up perhaps
they'd even promote scp-999 to the
position of under-secretary general and
perhaps even changed the meaning of the
group's acronym to givers of cuddles in
honor of their new leader and direction
we can dream right but let's end this
dream with a nightmare the scarlet king
the most dangerous being in the entire
multiverse who is also strongly believed
to be
scp-999's real father hmm awkward can
ultimate good someday defeat ultimate
evil according to ancient divate
prophecies a terrifying historical
culture that worshipped the scarlet king
yes it can if given the time and
nurturing it needs to reach full power
how exactly would that battle play out
well it's difficult to even theorize but
chances are it'd be a battle of truly
biblical proportions and if ever the
scarlet king did breach our dimension
it's safe to say that you'd want your
own little scp-999 close at hand and now
you can go to scp-swag.com and pre-order
a tickle monster plush of your very own
it doesn't even need any anomalous
powers to bring you a ridiculous amount
of joy orders placed in the next 10 days
get a special limited first edition card
so don't wait get yours now before
they're all gone now go check out
scp-999 the tickle monster and children
of scp-001 the scarlet king is scp-999
really his son for more on everyone's
favorite little creature